>>> NEW THIS MORNING, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP DENOUNCING THE
REMOVAL OF THE TOWERING STATUE
OF CONFEDERATE GENERAL ROBERT E.
LEE IN RICHMOND, YESTERDAY,
WHICH STOOD AS THE BIGGEST
CONFEDERATE STATUE IN THE
NATION.
IN ADDITION, HE SAID, IF WE ONLY
HAD ROBERT E. LEE TO COMMAND OUR
TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN, THAT
DISASTER WOULD HAVE ENDED IN A
COMPLETE AND TOTAL VICTORY MANY
YEARS AGO.
WHAT AN EMBARRASSMENT WE'RE
SUFFERING BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE GENIUS OF A ROBERT E. LEE.
JOINING US NOW, FORMER ASSISTANT
TO FORMER PRESIDENT GEORGE W.
BUSH, SCOTT JENNINGS.
I HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS.
LET ME ASK YOU, WHEN YOU READ
THE STATEMENT OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, WHICH, BY THE WAY,
INCLUDED A LOT MORE THAN THAT
AND CONVENIENTLY LEFT OUT THE
FACT HE CHOSE TO FIGHT AGAINST
THE UNITED STATES IN DEFENSE OF
SLAVERY, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF
THAT?
>> THERE WERE A LOT OF THINGS
GOING ON HERE.
THE FIRST PART ABOUT THE STATUE
PIECE, WE'VE HAD PANELS ON THE
SHOW ABOUT STATUE REMOVALS.
I HAVE NO USE FOR THE
CONFEDERATE STATUES MYSELF.
THERE'S A LOT OF POLLING ON
TRUMP'S POSITION ON THE STATUE
PART IS NOT A VALID POSITION.
I PREFER STATUES OF AMERICAN
HEROES LIKE GEORGE WASHINGTON.
WHERE THE STATUE PEOPLE WENT OFF
THE RAILS IS WHEN THEY STARTED
REMOVING NON--CONFEDERATE
STATUES.
YOU HAVE A TIME-TRAVELING ROBERT
E. LEE GOING TO AFGHANISTAN IS
ENOUGH FOR A BOOK, LIKE A SORT
OF HISTORICAL SCI-FI THRILLER OF
SOME KIND.
WHAT I THINK DONALD TRUMP IS
DOING, HE'S NOT STEEPED IN
MILITARY HISTORY.
YOU KNOW, HE'S AS LIKELY TO KNOW
AS MUCH ABOUT THIS AS HE IS TO
KNOW ABOUT BURT REYNOLDS' GREAT
SUCCESS AT CANNONBALL RUN OR
WHATEVER.
HE'S TRYI I ING TO REFLECT WHAT
THINKS PEOPLE WANT TO HEAR.
HE'S TRYING TO BE A MIRROR TO
CONSTITUENCIES ABOUT WHAT HE
THINKS WE WANT TO HEAR.
IT'S STUPID SOUNDING.
I WAS PICKING UP DIFFERENT
THINGS IN THIS STATEMENT AND WAS
SHOCKED BY IT, BUT NOT
SURPRISED, I GUESS.
>> HE'S SORT OF SEEING A FIZZ
EURO OR CHASM, AND HE'S TRYING
TO CLEVE IT OPEN AND DRIVE A
WEDGE IN THERE.
I'M WONDERING WHAT THE EFFECT
IS, SCOTT.
YOU SEE SO MANY REPUBLICANS
FOLLOW SUIT ON IT.
>> THE IDEA OF A CONFEDERATE
STATUE AND ROBERT E. LEE AND
INSERTING THAT OVER OUR DEBATE
IN THE AFGHANISTAN WITHDRAWAL,
WHEN WHEN THESE THINGS HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH EACH OTHER,
HE KNOWS THERE'S A CONSTITUENCY
OUT THERE THAT ROMANTICIZES
ROBERT E. LEE AND THE
CONFEDERACY.
IF ONLY WE HAD MORE TROOPS, HE
KNOWS THERE'S A CONSTITUENCY OUT
THERE.
HE KNOWS PEOPLE ARE MAD.
YOU TAKE TWO THINGS UNRELATED
AND STICK THEM INTO THE SAME
DEAL.
STRATTICLY I WOULD OFFER, THIS
AIN'T IT.
JOE BIDEN IS STRUGGLING RIGHT
NOW.
HIS APPROVAL RATINGS IS DOWN.
HE'S HAVING A DISASTROUS
PRESIDENCY, AND IT'S ON THE
DOWNWARD SWING BUT SORT OF
SAYING IF ONLY WE HAD MORE
ROBERT E. LEE AND SAVE US FROM
JOE BIDEN IS NOT THE WAY TO PUT
ANOTHER REPUBLICAN IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> HOW DO WE KNOW WHICH SIDE
ROBERT E. LEE WOULD BE FIGHTING
ON.
SCOTT, IN TERMS OF DIVIDING THE
BIDEN PRESIDENCY RIGHT NOW, THE
PRESIDENT IN THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
ASKED A NUMBER OF TRUMP
APPOINTEES WHO SAT ON MILITARY
ADVISORY BOARDS TO STEP DOWN OR
THEY WOULD BE REMOVED.
THEY INCLUDE FACES LIKE
KELLYANNE CONWAY AND DOUG
SPICER.
AS OF LAST NIGHT, I THINK, THEY
WERE REMOVED FROM THESE BOARDS
IF THEY DID NOT RESIGN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS?
>> YEAH, I THOUGHT IT WAS PETTY,
FRANKLY, BY JOE BIDEN TO DO
THIS.
YOU KNOW, THESE BOARDS OF
VISITORS FOR YOUR THE MILITARY
ACADEMIES ARE PRETTY PLUM
POLITICAL APPOINTMENTS TO THOSE
WHO DIDN'T QUITE MAKE IT TO THE
RANK OF AMBASSADOR.
I DID PERSONNEL FOR GEORGE W.
BUSH AND THOSE WHO DIDN'T BECOME
AMBASSADORS WOULD FIND THEIR
WAY.
THESE ARE REALLY GOOD
APPOINTMENTS.
THEY GO TO THE BIGGEST POLITICAL
SUPPORTERS.
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL FOR PEOPLE TO
PUT PEOPLE LIKE THIS ON HERE.
SOME ARE HIGHLY QUALIFIED TO BE
ON THERE.
THEN THEY HAVE TERMS AND WHEN
THOSE TERMS GO OUT, THE
PRESIDENT PUTS THEM ON.
I THOUGHT IT WAS EXTREMELY
PETTY, AND, FRANKLY, WHAT JOE
BIDEN IS GUARANTEEING IS
WHENEVER THE NEXT REPUBLICAN
COMES IN, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO GET WIPED AWAY.
I THINK THIS IS A STUPID TIT FOR
TAT WE'RE GOING TO GET IN HERE
ABOUT TRYING TO WIPE AWAY THE
PRESIDENT'S PREVIOUS
APPOINTMENTS ON BOARDS LIKE
THIS.
I THOUGHT IT WITH AWE REALLY
PETTY FRANKRY MOVE BY THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE.
>> CAN I ASK YOU, SCOTT, SHOULD
HE HAVE MAYBE DISTINGUISHED
BETWEEN SOME OF THESE
APPOINTMENTS.
YOU LOOK AT RETIERNT COLONEL
McGREGOR WHO'S A FAN OF
REPLACEMENT, THEORY, HAS RAILED
AGAINST WOMEN IN THE MILITARY IN
CERTAIN ROLE TS.
HEIDI STUR RUP.
THERE'S DIFFERENT CATEGORIES OF
PEOPLE HERE.
SHOULD THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
MAYBE HAVE BEEN MORE SELECTIVE
ABOUT WHO THEY WERE LOOKING AT?
DO YOU THINK THOSE PEOPLE REALLY
BELONG ON THE BOARD OF VISITORS?
THESE ARE FOLKS I WOULD POSIT
ANY O'REPUBLICAN WOULDN'T HAVE
APPOINTED.
>> I DIDN'T COME TO DEBATE THE
MERITS OF EACH OF THESE.
I'M TELLING YOU IT'S NOT NORMAL
FOR A NEW PRESIDENT TO WIPE AWAY
THE APPOINTMENTS OF THESE BOARDS
OF VISITORS AND OTHER KINDS OF
BOARDS AND DECISIONS.
IT DOES VIOLATE OUR NORMS FOR
BIDE ON THE DO WHAT HE DID HERE,
AND WHOULD I HAVE CHOSEN ALL
THESE PEOPLE?
PROBABLY NOT.
I WASN'T PRESIDENT.
THEY GET APPOINTED BY THE
PRESIDENT AT THE TIME.
I WOULD JUST OFFER THAT THIS
SORT OF -- THIS IS PETTINESS
THAT IS GOING TO PERPETUATE NOW
BECAUSE OF WHAT BIDEN HAS DONE.
BIDEN SORT OF RAN AS A GUY WHO
WAS GOEMG TO RESTORE THE NORMS.
WE'LL HAVE COMEDY IN WASHINGTON.
BIPART
BIPARTISANSHIP.
I THINK DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
REGR